los doce misioneros norteamericanos
retenidos durante dos meses por una
banda haitiana fueron liberados y son
trasladados al aeropuerto de puerto
príncipe los líderes de su organización
se sienten aliviados
dios es bueno dios ha respondido a
nuestras oraciones y nos alegramos
nos hemos quitado un gran peso de encima
y estamos preparados para la navidad
alabado sea el señor jesús
louis amor
el 16 de octubre 17 misioneros entre
ellos cinco niños de entre 8 meses y 15
años fueron secuestrados mientras
visitaban un orfanato desde entonces
había surgido poca información sobre las
condiciones de su cautiverio y
liberación vienen y creo que si hubiera
habido algún problema grave lesiones o
enfermedades probablemente nos habríamos
enterado
por lo que se están relativamente sanos
y la casa blanca por su parte reconoció
la labor de las autoridades haitianas
estamos agradecidos con el fbi y el
departamento de estado- y con las
fuerzas del orden de haití que han
trabajado incansablemente para atraer a
estos misioneros a casa sanos y salvos
los miembros de los 400 magos o la banda
criminal que secuestró a los misioneros
y que tiene fama de ser una de las más
peligrosas de haití había exigido un
millón de dólares por persona cautiva y
había amenazado en las redes sociales
con ejecutar a los rehenes este hecho
puso en el radar el nivel de inseguridad
inédito que atraviesa haití concentradas
en los lugares más pobres de la capital
las bandas criminales llevan a cabo
actividades lucrativas desde hace un año
de las que resaltan los secuestros de
personas principalmente haitianas según
un reporte oficial se habrían reportado
949 desde el comienzo del año